[Music]
hello I'm Evan I'm an engineer at Google
and hi I'm Dan an engineer at pivotal
Google and pivotal have been working
together the better part of this year
this is sorry Evan it's the best part of
this year I agree
we've been working to bring Cloud
Foundry to Google cloud platform and a
lot of folks on both sides were involved
today dan and I are going to talk about
some of that work we'll have more videos
in the coming weeks featuring other
engineers from both pivotal and Google
talking in-depth about service brokers
logging and monitoring but for today
it's me and you talking to the internet
about Bosch and Cloud Foundry now Evan
you picked up some work earlier this
year to bring Bosch to GCP can you talk
a little bit more about that sure Bosch
is a lot of things but our initial focus
was really simple and that was to make
it talk to Google's infrastructure we
made that work pretty quickly we
achieved that goal and then we set
loftier goals we wanted Google to be the
best place for Bosch to deploy
applications to especially things like
Cloud Foundry so those lofty goals that
we set included adding support for
Google's global network their global
load balancer and 30 second VM boot
times live migration and preemptable VM
pricing just to name a few and this work
you did it all with pivotal and it's
open source that's right all with
pivotal we spend a lot a lot of time
here in San Francisco with pivots like
yourself the work that we've done has
been on github since day one I think we
hit a lot of those lofty goals and I'd
like to show you by spinning up a Bosch
director on GCP and setting it up to
deploy some software all right sounds
great so I'm starting inside the GCP
console and I've got access to a
terminal here and the terminal is called
cloud shell and it's basically a free VM
or I can do things like deploy the
infrastructure that Bosch needs to run
so we're using terraform to do this
deployment its provisioning all of the
networking that's required for Bosch to
run and we've got this handy
architecture diagram that basically
shows the the bits that are there for
Bosch to run the most important thing is
that we would have a Bosch director and
that Bosch director is going to have a
private IP address so it's not sitting
on the public Internet but it is able to
talk to the
public internet through an at instance
to talk to the Bosch director directly
we have a bastion BM so you're able to
ssh into the bastion vm or use ssh agent
forwarding to do things like Bosch
Target and Bosch deploy so we use
terraform to provision all of this
infrastructure we do that from within
cloud shell and once we're inside our
Bosch bashed and VM we can use Bosch in
it to stand up that first Bosch director
this takes a little bit longer than
we're showing in the demo here we've
sped it up for time purposes but at this
point we've got that global network we
have our Bosch director up and running
and we would be able to deploy cloud
foundry or concours or any other basha
fide application and Dan I know you work
on cloud foundry at pivotal and you did
a lot of work to make it run really well
on Google cloud platform so would you be
able to talk a little bit about that
work sure one of cloud foundries biggest
selling points is its ability to run
great on many cloud platforms I'm
striking away boring details while
really exposing what makes a platform
unique to get it running great on Google
our engineers delve into the
infrastructure to really understand its
ins and outs and to figure out where
Cloud Foundry needed to change to run
perfectly so we spent a lot of time
focusing on networking configuration to
get the fast and solid networking that
Google is known for and bringing in
other services like Google cloud storage
for native blob stores very cool there's
a link below where you can follow a
tutorial to deploy open source cloud
foundry on Google cloud platform but Dan
I know there are other ways to get up
and running with cloud foundry on Google
could you talk a little bit about that
yeah totally a cloud foundry is a highly
customizable platform even down how its
deployed on our doc site at Doc's top
pivotal Daioh there's tons of
information about how you can configure
every part of your deployment with baj
if you'd like more control but if you're
looking for something a little bit more
hands-off we've got pivotal cloud
foundry or PCF which comes with ops
manager it's it's an appliance that
lives in your Google project and can
manage a lot of this deployment for you
very cool thanks everyone for watching
be sure to check out the tutorials in
the description and stay tuned for the
next videos in this series
where other pivotal and Google engineers
will talk about tools they built
including service broker and agree
logging and monitoring for Bosh and
Cloud Foundry on Google cloud platform
[Music]
hey be sure to check out this video of
my colleague Vic showing you how to
deploy a global multi-region claw
foundry installation and look at the
playlist for other videos in this series
and don't forget to subscribe to the
Google cloud Channel